pills is there something else
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're good this time right
quarter black okay we were just we just
started this and then uh something funky
happened with the youtube
this is actually the most nervous i've
been for an ash wednesday with a special
guest
i i don't want to say starstruck because
i don't want to be insensitive even
though i am
i
i want to make sure i get this right uh
you know dave do you can let your cigar
during the uh you can light it during
that no i'm trying i'm trying to do it
now yeah we'll light it during we have
and it's all right that your star struck
around me yes well
i
i never get over it dave
green room i urinate myself a little bit
i know i think that's also because i
have the plate in my head and quarter
black turns on the microwave uh look
show them who we have here piss my pants
forget who i am for a few minutes
merry christmas this is uh we have him
here kyle rittenhouse this is ash
wednesday
i don't know enough to know whether that
17 year old kid
exactly what he did but
allegedly he's part of a militia coming
out of the state of illinois have you
ever heard this president say one
negative thing about white supremacists
a 17 year old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people we must never allow
mob rule
17 year old being held on suspicion of
first degree intentional homicide you
see the 17 year old who was radicalized
by trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha
and became a killer
all right so uh he is here i want to
make sure that i get i have these notes
just to make sure i get all the names
right so that i get sued as opposed to
this young man uh
this is a kid who was thrust into a
situation that um
really through no fault of his own and a
lot of conservatives or people on the
right tried to do the uh
the both sides and we didn't a lot of
prayers said for this kid uh in the
studio and i think you all know how
emotional it was for us when uh
when he was vindicated and now he's on
social media so it's uh it's not and uh
kyle ryden house it's not fluffer boy
2004. unfortunately it is not fluffer
boy 2000. why do i have fluffer boy
tooth why do i have that here to my
understanding i believe that assistant
district attorney binge assistant
attorney district attorney oh i thought
it was boy fluff or two birds of a
feather yeah yeah unless ages
i'm not sure okay but one of them was
fluffer boy one of them but yours is on
facebook instagram tiktok
at this is kyle rittenhouse and on
twitter it's at this is kyle r that is
correct right
what are you using the
social for
well uh just to
show my life uh outside of the cameras
you're taking like pictures of your
cappuccinos and [ __ ]
my lattes yes my starbucks
a little bit of ladies right little
little bit of ladies yes yes how do you
like the boys that's okay too oh you
don't know we don't care only you
stephen oh well thank you
i'm gonna go he's she's sharp look at
this i know he said back over the uh and
so poised too uh
he's a polite young midwestern man yes
boy it's all this man
and brats we eat back in wisconsin
polite young man who takes out the trash
that's right i joke you know and i mean
he actually was cleaning up the trash in
kenosha yeah when was the last time you
was a you as a kid went went to a city
well went to a city where you worked you
know served as a lifeguard or your dad
lived to clean up vandalism and trash do
you ever remember doing that so that
whole thing doesn't jive with no it
doesn't shine i've gone to a city to buy
drugs when i was his age that's true
yeah he was uh
you're like a kid who's like you were
practicing to be an emt correct uh i was
a firefighter emt cadet at the antioch
fire department and i was a graze like
police explorer
what does that mean so um i learned what
police officers do it through a youth
program it's like sponsored by the boy
scouts of america okay um learning what
they do the career stuff um
get to hang out with a bunch of cool
cops and firefighters the real here uh
the heroes out there whoa oh he
corrected it i do mean to suggest that
nurses tick talking
are not the same as first responders i
won't put you in the hot seat but you
said it working let me let me ask you
man uh and i know you've been making the
media rounds now uh thanks for fitting
us in
you um
what's it like
what's the relief like
uh being acquitted um
so like you're walking up a mountain
with about thousand pound weights on
your ankle yeah and then it was a tether
and then you're ziplining it down that
relief oh yeah
because you fainted for real right i i
didn't faint my knees buckled in is that
what it was yeah as you could see i
thought you like overwhelmed with relief
that's when you get the real feeling of
just i can't well you know what i've
never had that it's got to be the
greatest moment oh 100 oh yeah and then
walking out me and uh me and the
sergeant for kenosha police department
really professional guy yeah we sprinted
down the hallway um yeah getting out of
that courthouse yeah i'm sure i guess
you could say that's the first time i
ran from a cop there you go
[Laughter]
usually you're running toward them yeah
your hands up with your hands actually
up saying uh this is exactly what
happened and that was all that was all
misrepresented so much this was
misrepresented i know every way i have
to be careful uh in what i ask you if i
ask you anything uh that you can't
answer yep no problem just tell me you
know you tell me to i'll i'll throw i'll
throw my mug at you well you know what
that's a that's a dangerous it's a
registered weapon i think those asbestos
tumblers really well those things are
light they're they're they're yeah they
go by feathers oh well i'm taking this
home with me okay well that's fine you
can take several home with you you
brought some dogs here too which uh you
know we're dog people
um
i don't know why that's relevant that's
like a stupid oprah question it is you
like dogs i love dogs yeah we should
really softball this whole thing yeah we
should softball this whole thing what do
you like waffles or pancakes yeah which
one i'm a i like crepes oh look at this
guy wow
i think i see a new instagram thing i
don't know why he's pinkies
it is treat yourself uh
what was okay i have i do have some
things that i genuinely just am curious
about
you were and i think a lot of people got
this wrong and by the way we'll be
taking some chat on uh mug club i keep
looking to the wrong camera because we
have it set up here for ash wednesday
live
um
guys you can comment please hit the like
button that's i'm only going to ask this
once because i don't want to interrupt
our conversation and we'll be taking
your uh your questions your chat uh
exclusively on mudclublescar.com
slash mug club after this um
so first let me ask you and i know joy
reid said this didn't happen
but she's an idiot yes uh
when the president
if not outright said their argument is
he didn't call you white supremist
supremacist he just inferred it and
showed a video of you uh with him
narrating about white supremacy i think
that's bad enough
what was that like when the president of
the united states former vice president
of the united states
was
dragging your name through the mud
before you even made it to trial
very disappointing uh biden is a former
criminal defense attorney so he should
know innocent until proven guilty but he
decided to go guilty before being proved
innocent well he didn't practice he
doesn't i mean if he did it was like for
six months he like clerked i mean he's
been suckling at the government the
public teaches his whole life since he
was like 27 years old yeah i've also
heard rumors his memories fading yes
unsubstantiated but uh mr president i
hope you see this i'd have a sit down
and i'll explain the facts to you um so
you can understand them
so he just uh heard uh he just heard a
cowbell a dinner bell and thinks that
you're asking him uh to come in for
pudding
that's not gonna help uh i don't think
he'll be having a meal three squares of
footing a day three square cups a day
uh
yeah but you're saying okay he's
were you scared did you think
did you think that the the fix is in at
that point when you see the you know
most powerful office in the land
sounding off in my mind i would go he's
emboldened here for a reason
were you were you scared i was terrified
like when i have all these media lying
media organizations the president coming
out and saying all these false things
that just are not true right it's just
like how could somebody get away with
that and not not be honest journalists
well the clintons killed a guy
is that true
allegedly these are rumors not hurt
sorry i don't want to misspeak nine guys
one girl that's good you weren't in the
cell alone yeah yeah
uh
they uh no really they uh they uh you
know
that must have been terrifying and then
it's even worse than that you know i
talked about this on on air you have the
entire media entertainment industrial
complex
you have the former vice president of
the united states joe biden every not
even liberal station i mean some backed
him up but yeah i mean every news
station jumped on white supremacy right
instantly but then in the trial
did was there ever a moment
where your blood ran cold when you when
you found out that the fbi
had either withheld or lost the hd
footage
did your blood did your blood run cold
when you i remember when i realized that
i thought oh no
they're going to railroad this kid um so
backing up a little bit with the fbi
footage
we figured out about it about a month
and a half prior to trial oh and we got
like a four minute video extremely
compressed
okay
sorry sprite oh yeah well that's okay
you're fine um don't worry about burping
that's the least offensive thing that's
taken place
um but we found out about that a month
and a month or so prior to trial
happening
and apparently the state had that for
several months that video and it wasn't
sent to us well um and when we got it
the state said it shows me chasing down
mr rosenbaum which is just it's false mr
rosenbaum chased me oh yeah we've said
and it's even in the fbi video so i'm
like it was in the it was in fluffer boy
uh 2004's opening statements where he
said and we have fbi footage that will
show mr rittenhouse was chasing
rosenbaum and i remember us hearing that
going oh how have they been sitting on
this how didn't how did it not make it
to discovery um i thought maybe there
was something i had missed and then he
showed it and well let's let's see it's
the exact opposite exactly what you said
exactly what he said
but
you obviously notice
it must have been did it come in waves
you're going oh the fbi wants a certain
outcome here it seems that way
um and then seeing that i'm like
i was like oh jesus is really good that
this is there's cameras and then the
second thought is i had why is the fbi
spying on u.s citizens yeah that was my
question too yeah is
how many other riots that were taking
place had drones or they claimed i think
at one point assessed now they can
actually a manned vehicle
how many other riots have this footage
footage of the man who shot david dorn
they have footage of the you know over
dozen people who were killed at these
riots the cops who were
and they haven't they haven't caught the
people who shot david doran have they i
don't know i don't know if they're
looking yeah i don't know if they're
looking and for people who don't
remember he's the man who was shot dead
uh was a long time st louis or an area
in missouri i don't know if it was saint
louis proper police officer who was
retired and uh shot in the street over a
television black guy by the way before
you go with a white supremacy angle
again um
that one odd when the one of the person
people who you defended yourself against
was screaming the n word over and over
again at a gas station oh that's a
question maybe it's a little bit light
so you know you were there when he was
screaming the n-word repeatedly
rosenbaum um i wasn't at that gas
station but i saw the videos but okay
the one time i did hear uh mr rosebomb
screamed the n-word i was alone i was
with ryan balch and he came up to us i
was asking people if they needed help i
was helping the writers with first aid
and then he came up he said i'm going to
[ __ ] kill you you n-word wow and then
the second time that's how we say n-word
but you can say [ __ ]
even though you're quoting someone else
and uh i think it's best yeah i think
yes i think it's best because uh we
played the clip and we were accused of
using the n-word on television because
we're like this is what he said i didn't
want to whitewash it
um so but sorry continue so this is when
you saw him
and then i was like okay and we moved
away from him
[Music]
you're like so you don't need help then
yeah like grandpa simpson walking into
the brothel and walking back out when he
sees bart
so
okay so red flag
yeah um
very big red flag he was setting fires
everywhere i saw him set a trailer on
fire he's walking around with a chain
and a mental hospital bag is that that's
right yeah that's what he threw at you
did you when he threw it at you did you
know you're like oh my god percocet like
did you
did you see what was in it i um i didn't
know what it was in it i thought it was
a metal chain because i was shining
through the light yeah it's not a metal
chain now but right that's what i saw
when i was thrown if nothing else we
have to say about rosenbaum that he um
he's a renaissance man in the armaments
that he chooses yes i was surprised he
didn't go with a zip gun he went with a
chain he did i respect that he did uh he
was snapping did you notice though to me
what i saw was not just him screaming
the n-word
but that there were black guys around
him i didn't do anything which tells you
he's really crazy they were just like oh
my god yeah when you don't punch that
guy he really seemed
insane like he really did seem did you
get that vibe when you're like yeah did
you get that just advised of danger i
guess i noticed if somebody who
um was like threatening to kill me i'm
like nobody threatens to kill somebody
that's
it's not normal well i threatened to
kill dave all the time it's okay you
guys have a little bit of a romance
going on we do well yeah we've already
spit in his mouth i'm like come on
stephen we all saw behind the scenes i
say surprise me with it yes that's he
just goes he shows up in a corset and
says do you like surprises that's how i
like my coffee
so i i had to i had to ask steven to
change he was wearing lingerie for dave
before i came here that's true well i
wouldn't call it lingerie because i'm
french canadian plus there's
way too much exposure yeah i would call
it a string i mean i wouldn't yeah well
i mean honestly with just a pair of
socks it likes me to wear a little
something yeah there's definitely some
stuff popping up yes they're they're got
the doi leafs on them so
uh sorry we're going back to rosenbaum
but uh the fbi to me that was
what just sucks
my attention is aimed at this
child and not this child
yeah yeah
uh i got a seaguar
so
the fbi though to me that was really
scary i think for a lot of people they
realized okay
in this case i don't want to turn
feather one at the fbi in this case
there's a politically charged agenda if
they didn't give them this footage at
least behind someone right yeah
yeah but i in this case i didn't really
i didn't see this as a political case i
saw this about a case of self-defense
that's how i looked at i know a lot of
people disagree with me
but that's how i saw it yeah well i
think that's what it was it was it was
the right time for the media to build up
uh the story that they wanted and they
used you and that's terrifying i'm sure
yeah especially just being a normal 17
year old kid who was attacked and next
thing i know
um everybody in this world apparently
knows who i am yeah what time can't i
imagine i don't want to you know you let
me know if i'm
attacked by a
i mean you didn't know at the time a
child rapist uh who and this is not just
this isn't
this has nothing to do with you
exercising right to self-defense but it
also goes back to this idea of the sort
of these reforms that we've seen this is
a guy who really probably should have
been locked away for life
based on the crimes that he had
committed just like you see people in
new york you know with this sort of cash
bail they go out and they commit violent
crimes again
and uh
unfortunately law-abiding citizens are
the ones who get vilified you know
people would say well you had no
business being there
i never said that because i don't
believe that
uh i think it's a lot easier for people
to say
i'm justifying why i wasn't there i
think a lot of people thought you know
what this is a kid who's trying to do
the right thing because no one is and a
city where he works and he has close
ties is is ablaze
if
i know you probably would if you could
do it again you wouldn't go hindsight
being 2020 yes i would have stayed home
i'd say paying 2020 but we can't change
that and it doesn't change the fact that
i was attacked and defended myself no
absolutely but you would have stayed
home just because you would you'd rather
avoid all this exactly i can't imagine
being 18 i mean and i know it's got to
be difficult for you to have to you know
deal with all of this but like why did
you go out that night that's what i
guess because it people so many people
he was there before that night oh you
were there before the night yeah you
were there before i was there that
morning cleaning graffiti off of
rutherford central high school with
donald trump and my sister
and ray
um and then i stayed the night at
dominic's house the night prior and we
had fish for dinner that night yeah
see i just think people need to hear
that though because they there's this
fish yeah was it good would you have
your tilapia was it a halibut halibut
bluegill chips oh yeah i don't know why
bluegill chips really good one of my
favorite foods really yeah that's very
specific you're going to be a very good
instagram foodie yeah people are going
to love it is
food is everything and explains the gut
it's almost bigger than dave's please
good lord
but he's right you can unload on the kid
now all right listen here we came to
play
they will play
uh no look i want i want you to uh look
you want to puff at this cigar take a
puff of the cigar oh
i know look i saw you smoking cigarettes
and i know that this kid wants a cigar i
feel like you've been on trial for worse
things why don't you want a puff of the
cigar
things okay i will not say that that
this kid uses nicotine in any form or
fashion well i have a real question
how much call of duty experience did you
have yes
i think that's what's on all of them and
how did you unlock idr 15 which isn't
available in the game
but i was prestige 27 in call of duty
okay before this all happened wow
now i'm only like prestige sex i don't
know what that means i don't have a clue
did you rescue the princess uh i didn't
rescue the princess
yes that the very yeah if i rescue the
princess you'd be right here with me
yeah oh there you go well we have dave
um that's good enough can i get a tiara
yes and only a tiara yeah i'll be back
with socks and a tiara
what
what do you think was the most important
lesson that you learned not hindsight
2020 wouldn't go down there
but in all of this what was your big
takeaway besides the relief of not you
know being acquitted my biggest takeaway
is how the government can just
try to push their own narrative on staff
unsuccessfully in my case but they can
only they can push their own agenda and
just try to put anybody away for
defending themselves or
any innocent person what do you think
would have happened if there wasn't uh
more footage than people could watch in
a lifetime stephen we wouldn't be here
no
you think you'd be locked up i think i'd
be in jail if there wasn't all these
videos and that's most people
that's to me what's so scary yeah if
there was all the footage and it didn't
matter anyway that's when people say
we're divided in this country as though
we we need to reach across the aisle
where i go well look there's all of this
footage
and it doesn't matter anyway i think
that you were
uh really a line in the sand for a lot
of people for them to wake up
if if there wasn't any of this footage
the state would have been able to push
their own narrative
and
say what they wanted to say and they may
have gotten away with it did you feel
when the jury was deliberating that
there was a good chance that they were
com looking almost for a guilty plea
because it was taking so long
i don't know i i don't know what what
happened in that deliberation room i
don't know if i'll ever know
but
after after the second day i was getting
nervous oh i bet you were there was
probably one soccer mom hold on
yeah probably but i was there karen on
the jury uh i'm not sure you have to say
the type what's everyone saying what's
going on guys are you uh are we okay are
we good okay cause kyle's looking at i
know they're walking around here right
like uh like the keebler elves they're
distracting me yes i know i'm
distracting all of us as well come on
this kid just let this kid tell his
story you guys are distracting let him
tell his truth
um
you uh
you said you're burning your ar-15 uh
i'm having it destroyed destroyed right
yeah because burning it probably
wouldn't uh work yeah
why is that well it's just something i
don't need um i don't want it back on
the street um i had to defend myself
with it i don't think it should be
propped up in a museum like a lot of
people think i think it just needs to be
destroyed
oh they gave it back to you no no i'm
gonna have i'm requesting we're putting
in a motion oh that's what it is for the
police department to send it off to be
destroyed and i think we're gonna send
one of our guys
one of our people with it to make sure
it is destroyed okay are you gonna get
another one i don't know
you're gonna get some fire i don't know
he's gonna get a firearm no yeah i don't
i i might have to i'll get a nerf gun
yeah he might you know he's gonna
because you know just piss off the
pedophiles that's a good way to go about
it
you might see that i don't know about
buying it i don't know if a nerf gun
with a serial child rapist that's like a
rape whistle that calls more rapists i'm
not sure i think so it's nerf or nothing
i haven't seen that it's not gonna be
nothing i haven't seen the ads for this
christmas
what do you want for christmas what do i
want for christmas yeah i got my
christmas gift freedom
there you go there you go but what do
you really want from me yeah
besides freedom yeah besides freedom oh
what i mean that's a good that's a good
answer amy grant
listen i'm going to ask some questions
nobody's asked yet because people want
to know i mean i'm him saying that he uh
he wants freedom for christmas i think
it's a good uh well we're not going to
have it much longer so we might as well
enjoy it while we can right so what do
you have anything that you want
specifically what do i want for
christmas oh
everybody in this world to just stop
fighting and unite as one instead of
being politically divided just everybody
to be together well they're kind of
doing it with china we're gonna have to
move on down
um i don't think that one's coming down
your chimney this year what would i like
something that we could buy for you take
a hint yeah we'll send you some you want
to ride two speed boats like skis he'll
pay for it
uh
we can make it happen yeah at least
lease them for a couple of months
just be with family um eat food um
spend time with family and relax yeah
yeah how long were you locked up i was
in jail for 87 days
dang what was that do i have you tapped
dave uh you do have me talk oh how long
yeah i had only been in jail like a few
days at a time and then i was locked up
once uh in a mental hospital for 20 and
then
uh
60 maybe in a rejuvenal rehab
for yeah different childhood yeah i
wasn't like you i wouldn't have been
going there i would have been well if
people had drugs for sale
you were going through everyone's trust
me if i saw the cops i'm not running at
them when i'm 18 no he's absolutely not
and you are running at the hospital bags
are you going what's in it yeah oh no
certainly i would look through and be
like oh cool lithium he used to wait
outside of the mental hospital and pop
people in the head so they dropped their
bag like a pinata you say oh look
vicodin percocet great and he would grab
him made a lot of money he's a
degenerate it's okay degenerate let me
ask you uh let me ask you this
uh
i wanted to ask because i saw your
reaction
when bingo asked i think it was i want
to make sure i get this name right so it
was richie mcginnis
where binger said and you had no idea
that he was reaching for kyle's gun or
he was trying to take cal's gun and
richie mcginnis said who was called by
finger the prosecution said yep well he
reached for his gun and said [ __ ] you so
i saw you start kind of trying to hide
back as intense as it was a smirk do i
have that about right
yeah um so i was i was like
i was like why is he asking these
questions like this is what richie was
saying this is what i was hearing and
saying yeah like it's on video
yeah but were you dumbfounded as to how
flufferboy 2004 could ask that question
he rightly admitted it i mean did that
give you a huge amount that's right
yeah i was gonna get to that oh i
thought no this is the guy who was with
him who uh no sorry i always get them
confused this is richard mcginnis
richard mcginnis he was the one who saw
the
guy reach for your gun yeah that guy saw
the guy reach for the game so that was a
big one but i remember you smirking at
that
but then did you go
that's the moment that changed the case
when uh gage grosskroots
admitted that you only shot when he came
up and aimed at you because that was for
everyone here we said whoa when that
happened live um well
the i i i didn't think they had a case
from the beginning when they started off
their opening statements with lying to
the entire jury right and then putting
on a witness dominic who helped me
i thought the prosecutor was your lawyer
yes that's what we thought at first we
were confused he's really bad at this
and i have my attorneys are great mark
richards score shrapsey they're and
natalie wisco they're great attorneys
phenomenal i don't think i would have
been able to get off without them yeah
even though you say you know that they
didn't have a case of prosecution and
they were lying but it still must be in
the back of your mind that you know they
can railroad you if they want yep 100
percent um and then with the gage
testimony
um
he was it attorney sharaphasy said it
wasn't until
you chased him down
lunged at him went for his gun and
pointed a gun at him until he shot you
correct and then he said yes and i
that's when you see me have a huge sigh
of like
did you feel like okay pretty confident
after that that
at least i won't be uh
convicted on like the the severe murder
charges they were trying to press did
you feel like okay i'm out of the woods
the moment that happened there was a
shift in your attitude um
not really um i i stayed optimistic the
entire trial um
but
it was more like at least he's honest
right
or high yeah
most likely the latter yeah most likely
the latter and i want to go two more
questions on gage gross cruz who's
beautiful and brave he um then went on
good morning america and other shows
to
uh
talk about cultural appropriation of
spaces i'm surprised he doesn't have
ringlets on his neck his name was gage
and he had ear gage i just thought it
was a pro wrestler name but then he went
on good morning america i believe with
uh uh is it michael strait yeah and then
he goes on good morning america and just
lies about his he said the exact
opposite of his testimony because he's
not under oath well yeah say whatever he
wants i think it's like he just lied i
think there's i can't think of the name
but he perjury to himself he perjured
himself yeah he perjured himself and i'm
like yeah just tell him
you might need to learn those two well
he said on the stand i believe that he
said i'm going to effing kill you right
uh no gage grosskritz said on the stand
that he pointed his gun at kyle right
yeah
he admitted that he himself first person
aimed a gun at you and then he lied in
office police reports he said he was
going to help me because i was being he
saw me being attacked right and then he
said weird way to help these are the
reports where he failed to mention that
he had a gun these are the reports where
he
doesn't mention that he has a gun kind
of a big deal yeah you would think like
oh and by the way you remembered all
these details it's only a homicide trial
you may want to include that you had a
gun he included a ton of details i mean
he remembered if you were wearing boxers
or briefs but he didn't remember they
had a glock 27. i thought it was odd
yeah exactly well and he drove farther
that was amazing yes
he's like he lives 35 miles farther than
you you know he didn't know the guy just
like just someone i'm like can someone
get this guy an old vhs of dora the
explorer get the map song here he has no
clue um that's another thing where
people thought you went into this
foreign city that yeah connections with
kenosha was part was my community i my
dad lived in kenosha my friend my best
friend lived in lived in kenosha yeah um
and that was just my community i hung
out there every day i spent more time in
kenosha than i did in illinois um
and for that whole state line crossing
stuff i worked in kenosha and i had to
cross multiple state lines to get here
stephen yeah well especially people
understand who don't live in the midwest
you know uh i was born in michigan and
my wife was raised there you know you're
driving from we would do that drive all
the time from michigan to chicago my mom
lived here i grew up in michigan oh
where did she go
uh you know where wellstone is
no do you is it northern northern i have
no idea uh by cadillac yeah oh yeah yeah
sure yeah cadillac yeah but northern
michigan that's a beautiful area well
he's a he's a detroiter too and you know
i mean ohio michigan indiana i can go to
illinois
detroit really midwest though people
argue about that they do like
robocop in midwest it's more apocalyptic
yeah it's uh no i love detroit but i i
always considered it like north really
it's basically canada it's like right on
the fringe yeah it is different from
wisconsin yeah you can have a cigarette
there i believe it's 19. oh or 18.
you're still in canada yeah right well
you can drink i don't know if you can
have a cigarette oh i don't know what
the rules are don't get them in trouble
trying to get me in trouble well you
just said well first off you're canadian
over here yeah you want so you just said
perfect you you now are saying because
you want i you wanted to be a nurse i
remember reading that and being
surprised yeah and i said you know what
names go and be a nurse but uh please
make sure that you never have to work
again as far as the uh the media you
know pulling nick sandman this is what i
was thinking you don't have to answer
that what is with that though where
you're going into a school correct
and i'm at college and yeah college you
are in college now yeah but he's
switching he wants to become a lawyer
that's what i was going to ask him oh
i'm sorry no no go ahead uh but there
was like people protesting that is that
is that true that is correct okay what
college what what for that at arizona
state university is that where you're
going yes that's where i'm at
herpes my friend um
just don't show up to the wrestling mate
the last concussion was
hpv
yeah uh next video uh steven's gonna be
me and you wrestling oh jeez did you
wrestle yeah i'd wrestled for a little
bit in high school oh wow okay well then
i mean uh middle school okay so are you
still there though is it business online
i would assume yeah it's online i took
compassionate withdrawal from my classes
my professors well my professors offered
it and then a week later they
gave me a compassionate withdrawal which
thank you for that um
but then they came out with a statement
saying oh no no no no he's he's not
enrolled at
asu anymore i'm like i'm enrolled i'm
just not in any classes i'm admitted i
have a student portfolio right so even
like we are taking as checks
yeah even when you're innocent that's
something have you learned here even if
you're innocent they're the court of
public opinion is very different have
you yeah and it's not they're worrying
about a lot of protesters there no it
was a very very small amount yeah and
then people are just like let him get an
education right i'm like yes that's what
i want to do i want to go to law school
i'm gonna i'm going to asu
in the spring in person i want to do my
four-year undergrad there before i take
the lsat and go do my three years of law
yeah but hopefully before you finish you
own don lemon's house but you yeah
switch from nursing to law that's is
that because of the
i heard you mentioned prosecutorial
misconduct yes you want to be a defense
attorney i do i want to be a criminal
defense attorney okay i think you're
going to do very well
i'm
i'm
a big on no matter who the person is i
believe everybody deserves
fair and good legal representation like
oj
so john demetrius she selected the oj
simpson jury
she helped select my jury she's a
phenomenal jury consultant
she's more than that for us though she
was more she was a rock for my mom
somebody my mom can lean on and
hold during this entire
deal yeah how is she doing i remember
watching that that looks sick i mean it
was three times that i've cried on this
show or come close to it
on air when my dog yeah on air uh when
my
uh when hopper died
and i had to talk about it
when
david dorn
we watched that footage
and we all about lost it when you
were crying on the stand it was really
really hard for all of us to one of the
hardest things was me keeping my
composure and then seeing your mom
how has she been doing now is she she's
she's relieved she's doing so much
better um i think she's a little mad at
me right now but that's that's okay why
is she mad because oh um i still smoking
cigarettes no she doesn't smoke anymore
no you she because you're smoking the
cigarettes yes yes
uh no what is she mad what did she make
pressure i think i left drawn red or
something
you left away
yeah i think i left my mom on red this
morning or something red i i didn't
reply back to her oh okay i didn't know
oh
i don't know about your call of duty
prestige term
texting
you don't play call of duty stephen no
i'm married and have twins you have
twins yep just just happens and i didn't
play call of duty before congratulations
thank you very much yeah uh both boys
are both uh one boy one girl nice so
identical
yeah i don't uh they look just like i
don't fully understand gold beard and
everything he looks like me he does when
he smiles he has you know he has the the
weak jaw unfortunately a little upturned
nose uh and she looks thank goodness
more like her mother we didn't want uh
one of those billy joel daughter
situations going around where she comes
out could look like her mom but she
looks like me yeah a monster would call
them a butterface and i'm not that
person yes a monster could have looked
like christy brinkley daughter joel yeah
isn't that crazy came out looking like
the piano man
um so i'm glad so your mom is doing
better yep same with my sisters um
they're doing good they're hanging out
at home uh relaxing they may be going on
vacation sometime um
but they're just hanging out with
friends catching up on everything we
missed because we all had to put our but
they had to thank thank you to them they
had to put their lives on on hold for
all of this
are they
going through any sort of therapy or
counseling since this because i would
imagine it's
not i don't want to say as traumatic for
them but in a different way definitely
definitely yeah um because you're
because you're in it but for them
there's also the trauma of
feeling completely helpless yeah but
they've been so helpful to this all um
especially my mom she's been really
she's she's been really good through
this entire thing
yeah that was
that was really hard to watch because
you're watching it live on the show and
and to be honest i had listened to so
much rhetoric on the news that it said
he was a white supremacist there's
almost this view that you went down
there and like i'm clean dave what
tell him what you thought before you
were in the show i did i i thought that
he was he thought he thought you know
what the media told and then he was on
this show because all i had heard was
cnn going he's a white supremacist like
i figured you went down there in like a
maga hat and we're like you know they
wanted you to believe that you were
hunting people so i watched the trial
going into it when because we started
covering it
and it was almost immediate where i'm
like wait this is everything i've heard
so far just in the uh the one attorney's
opening statements
shows that you weren't anything that
they painted i can't tell you how many
people when i would talk with them in
person would say
wait
the people he shot were white guys
yeah people didn't know after you were
acquitted that you had shot three-way
and that's the thing uh people don't do
their research i urge anybody to go back
and watch the trial i'm sure stephen
will link it in the description we'll
link it we'll have all the references
yeah um yeah we have to so anybody just
if you don't know the facts just go back
and watch the trial spend like two and a
half weeks watching it
and just learn the facts of the case and
then and then make up your opinion after
what do you think is the most if people
have to come away with one or two the
most important key facts that the public
perception
about which is wrong what do you think
is the key fact that people think or the
misperception that people have that is
most pervasive
that i didn't cross state lines and that
rifle i was carrying was 100 legal for
me to carry
dude that is the one that i keep having
to tell people as well i i think you're
right i think that is the number one
thing that is completely uh because i i
saw an article today where they're like
he crossed state lines and carried an
illegal firearm and i think it was
an article that said i was in
self-defense but they said i crossed
state lines and my firearm was illegal
right why does that one bother you more
than the idea of white supremacist is it
why is that the one that sticks in your
cross so much that's the one i hear the
most um that and again on the white
supremacist stuff it's just false right
yeah it's not like
that was the first charge dismissed too
the uncharted firearm charge because
from the beginning i said uh i don't
think he's going to get quarter black
disagreement that he was like i don't
know i think they're going to railroad
this kid i said i genuinely believe that
he will be acquitted
because of how murky to be fair some
lawyers can you know use the legalese of
the firearm laws in wisconsin i thought
maybe they might need to try and make an
example of this and get them on some
kind of a firearms charge but that
doesn't mean that it's right when they
dismissed that one i thought okay we're
cooking with gas now
did you feel that momentum shift uh no
not really i didn't think that in my
opinion i don't think the gun had any
bearing on the right to self-defense
right at all so i was just i wasn't
really worried i mean more so on seeing
like okay there might be some
objectivity here you know what i mean
because that was something that everyone
said and it was dismissed right the
people in charge said no we're not going
to play that well and even the footage
they had to show because so many people
were like oh you were pointing it at
people this and that like yeah all the
footage show that you weren't yeah i
didn't point my firearm at anybody who
wasn't attacking me exactly yeah and
that was honestly amazing uh i know i
wouldn't have been so composed
uh i want to ask you about that i don't
know if you can answer this you can
always tell me if you can't because gage
said that you he used the term or
re-racked your gun
and this was something that was it came
from his twitter by the way to the point
where when we were trying to get the key
details from the case we were wrong we
issued a correction saying
he
doesn't appear that kyle actually did
that but it was everywhere and it
stemmed from gage's twitter
it did not happen so i never pulled the
charging handle back i never went
through i never pulled that but i did
hit the forward assist to close the
ejection port which was open a little
bit okay
and uh was that training too that you um
did you have firearms training before no
no i i knew i don't i don't know much
about firearms but i knew that the
forward assist will close the bolt if
it's a little bit open right beginner's
luck
yeah
for christmas that was unbelievably uh
quick
and uh yeah i mean seriously dude that
shows your adrenaline and how afraid you
were i mean and when you did break down
on the stand
i do have this question because i i know
that was hard and if you don't want to
relive it just say so but aren't you
bothered by the fact that immediately
people were like always faking like
because what you're just meryl streep
yeah and you can do the greatest acting
i wasn't he wasn't sleeping with harvey
weinstein
oscars
like look it took everything i had i had
an anxiety attack i had people i had a
ptsd episode on the stand you're going
to that's what i said when it happened
he was faking i said i've i've had panic
attacks and i now have you had panic
attacks before that oh yeah when i was
in jail i had quite a few of panic
attacks oh i bet that the first time you
exactly since uh
since after
last time i was before the trial was in
jail okay and then i learned how to
control it with like your first panic
attack was in jail had you ever
experienced panic attacks before that
before jail no
so you know i've had them
uh a handful of times in my life i can
count on one hand um and it bothers me
when people go oh my gosh i was so
anxious i had a panic attack i go no no
you don't know
difference not social anxiety that you
fix with your weed it's a physiological
response
and we were live i remember saying he's
having he's having a panic attack
and it just makes it it just it's very
upsetting because i don't care what
people say
i've i've longed to live past that yeah
um but i'm like
i took everything i had to fight back
because i didn't want to cry on national
tv well that's the hardest part about a
panic attack is i i get them too is the
more you're trying to stop it they get
worse it exacerbates it yeah absolutely
right yeah and uh and uh respectfully i
told people look if he was going to fake
cry he wouldn't fake ugly cry yeah right
yeah i mean true it wasn't a
distinguished crime it wasn't like a
lone you know native american tear
looking at a trash bag in the wind it
was uh a clint eastwood you didn't you
know you didn't look like uh the most
dashing shooter uh while that was
happening and steven i thought it looked
good
yeah you do it in the mirror beforehand
great
good i'm going to be aces no i when we
were watching it live remember we said
that and then it was yeah and i said
watch they're going to say that he's
faking oh i knew right away and right
away and that just
i think we all watched we felt like you
were a little brother honestly everyone
here this was the most per we had taken
this more personally than anything else
because
you know we have to be careful too
because uh if if we try and raise that's
a problem for you if we try and raise
money for you if we try and i've been on
the phone with my lawyer what can we do
the best thing you can do is cover this
accurately from the get-go um but i know
that we had reached out to you behind
the scenes and wanted to keep you know a
healthy distance because i'm sure you
have every tom dick and harry now
knocking on your door offering you
internships or probably you know
broadcast or book deals
i'm not interested in any internships uh
respectfully no yeah what about book
deals uh i don't know uh i don't know
they've been offers right uh i don't
think so but i'll see what the future
holds children's book when you were in
jail uh so we'll do a coloring book a
pop-out yeah well um we'll do a coloring
you'll just pop out like surprise [ __ ]
that's it it's one page yeah it's just
one page
just one page about trigger control
um what did you read in jail i'm curious
about that um i read the entire maze
runners series um
i read i read so much in jail yeah i've
never read so much of my life i didn't
have my phone
yeah probably a good thing no
no i thought you were like i learned a
lot about myself like no i wanted to be
tick-tocking yeah well i wanted to be
posted on four doors more [ __ ] yeah
that's what that's right that was
brought up that was yours i don't see
how being hilarious is a problem
guilty yeah done and not to be the
elephant in the room the only thing
hilarious
is dave's got hanging out oh
i'm just kidding shots fired huh
that was a bad joke he's gonna play
santa next week he's getting in
character no i i i eat a lot of fish yes
was it blue
it was bluegill yes bluegill we have to
try that bluegill i don't know if i've
eaten bluegill we're from michigan where
everything is white fish
and that's it can be it's it's fine but
like a lot of old you guys have like
salmon there and everything yeah we do
but for some reason they bring out the
white fish first and it's uh it smells
like how fish dying hurts beach does
yeah perch you're at the uh what's that
place where the chelsea cafe they have
good perch you know what's really good
mahi
mahi-mahi
is good is one of my favorite fish it's
a very lean fish you ever have a there's
a place in uh manhattan beach i think
it's a franchise
and they do grilled mahi mahi really
manhattan no good dog
beach
oh yeah yeah manhattan beach california
oh yeah oh my gosh
one it used to be a white supremacist
haven
which one yeah well i guess i repeat
myself um and now you got me off track
sorry i'm sorry we were talking about my
fat ass eating fish
well he was the one who brought up your
fat ass eating look i thought i wore
something slimming you know what it's
okay me and you both damn you don't i
know you have you should get together
fish together let's do it kyle and i
have perfect bodies short stout
you don't look good in them look good on
the stand to hurt with your words kyle
let that be a lesson to you dave has
feelings too i don't have many not many
i have pretty much damaged from all the
years of drugs so
you read the mage runner series
like were you reading any law books i
guess that's what i was watching like no
they didn't have any law books um and
they're like we don't want you to yeah
we don't want you to figure out what
they got out of this that's smart that's
actually smart i would not allow any
prisoners access to law books for the
same reason i don't want them to have
access to the gym yeah let's send these
violent criminals stronger into society
than they were before never got it
i i'll have to disagree with you on that
one stephen i i believe everybody has a
right to exercise because
getting working out is a huge like
stress reliever and it's something else
to focus on and reading law books i
think you should be able to know the law
if you're going through a criminal
proceeding right but i'm just saying
like someone's on death if someone's on
death row there's nothing wrong with a
nice like yoga dvd yeah he doesn't need
to be doing uh you know he doesn't need
to be doing heavy bench press well they
don't have weights i mean you were in
prison i think they have like they
didn't have a gym at the juvenile plates
but like i don't think they have any
weights it's just like push-ups and like
sit-ups and stuff and how was your
treatment yeah no they were very
professional and nice to me the guards
yeah what about you
the kids at the juvenile center they
didn't like me at first um
they would like be like oh
yeah and then
i'm sure it was quite a bit more severe
than that yeah i wouldn't imagine if if
i went into jail and they were barking
through the bars
gross i'd be like i got off easy
oh yeah oh what did they really like
they didn't like you what kind of things
would they do how would they mess with
well they wouldn't mess with me at all
but they just would like they just
didn't like me until they got to know me
and then i'm i'm like a king of spades
now so i'd like
i'd like run the spades table oh so
thank god that's what you meant yeah
yes you run this what is this dave what
were you doing in jail
what's what's spades is that a game that
i don't know it's again you don't know
space i don't know what spades are no
it's a card game i had a legendary uno
run for four years that my dad this
man's been nowhere near a jail no
nowhere near jail uh i actually almost
got sent to jail for jumping a metro
turn style in montreal it was turns out
it was a serious i don't know a
different level of misdemeanor or felony
wow the week before and they changed the
law what a lame story you should never
tell no i should never tell it again uh
this went nowhere but i think it's fun
we're just i had an uno run that you can
talk with after this with darren about
my pops crowder uh they thought i was
cheating so that's the only card game i
played because once i had a four year
run i just retired on top like rocky
martial you weren't playing weren't you
steven i hand to god i was not cheating
i don't know what it was for four years
undefeated and we would play all the
time
but i never played space because you
know when you find what you're good i
just played uno so what are you doing
what are spades how is that do you know
euchre no okay maybe that is just a
michigan thing well that's yuper he's
from wisconsin oh right that's right
now sorry it's still michigan uh the
kind wisconsin yeah but did we win a war
for that yeah i don't i don't know
exactly i don't know why it's there
or michigan really they're all on
packers jackets yeah
um
do you have a this is a traumatic
experience right we're obviously making
light of it uh because that's sometimes
a way to process it yeah yeah it's the
only way to process it do you have ptsd
do you think uh yeah my uh strengths
that i did but it took me a while to
believe that
why didn't you believe the shrink you
know because like i'm like no i'm fine
i'm normal my ego got the best of me
apparently yeah you're like ah water off
an air 15's back
well i mean i imagine you're going to be
you're in therapy i would imagine yeah
yeah and yes you're going to have a you
have ptsd yeah do you have like
recurring dreams about it um
i have nightmares occasionally um they
definitely have slowed down over the
past couple weeks but good do you have
uh like what they would call like memory
avoidance
um sometimes sometimes but not a lot
okay um i start off into space a lot
yeah well you're you're 18. you're 18.
yeah
you're thinking of you're probably
thinking about girls like he thinks
about uh about smack no i'm thinking
about you stephen well thank you
whoa geez he it wouldn't be so
uncomfortable if you weren't just
denigrating his physique he wasn't doing
it's
he was even where's the atlas chaps i
saw the bulk eggs in the coffee he was
saying we match in physique because we
both eat a lot of fish
all right well then i guess i don't know
who you want to date
it comes as a couple yeah
it's a pig on a spit let's make this
weird so you do have uh ptsd yeah um
well of course uh yeah i would say of
course i didn't want to you know
diagnose you like nobody but i wanna
hear that i think it's just being honest
you have you know like pierce morgan or
something but your your psychiatrist
said that
what do you
what are you doing to to deal with that
talking to my shrink
talking about it with her really helps
um
very smart lady
um talking to the people in my circle
such as dave lt ken atc
people who have been with me from the
beginning because you have a lot of
friends that are
got your back yeah
more than friends they're mentors
they've taught me so much throughout
this i've grown so much because of them
they're just amazing like
who dave helped me with so much same
with lt and came on we just imagined
cool day oh that helped me
cool dave not you
less cool dave so that's good you have
it you have a strong support system yes
okay that's good that's important you
need it's very important when it's it
seems yeah if you have family and
friends that have always been on your
side and been there it's got to help
kind of uh take away the darkness that
was yeah
it was being given i know you said that
you didn't it wasn't something that uh
should be celebrated that is correct
but you don't feel guilt for what you
had to do no no i knew i defended myself
and i just don't think it's something to
be celebrated out at the end of the day
two lives were lost and yeah i may have
been attacked but it's not something to
celebrate i don't think it's something
to celebrate and i asked that because i
if you said that you did i would this
would be an intervention that you should
not feel any guilt and i know sometimes
there's misplaced guilt when there's
a traumatic uh event
um well that's when somebody does the
right thing yeah i mean really i think
for the most part but soldiers
it's not something to be i understand
what you're saying to be celebrated but
and what i talked about on air is
you were there trying to do the right
thing that's why i never took a step
back like yeah he shouldn't have been
there no i understand why you were there
and actually commend you for being there
because you were there for a long time
cleaning up and helping you weren't one
of these people and i'm saying this look
and you're gonna have to take this
praise for a second you just let me let
me give him this praise you weren't
there taking and harming lives like the
people who attacked you they all and
this is relevant you didn't know it at
the time but they all spent a lifetime
harming other people you have not you
were there to help and i don't think it
was wrong for you to be there and i
think it's important that you know even
though you don't think it's something to
be celebrated and i understand the
sentiment
i certainly celebrate
that that occurred rather than the
alternative because
i know that if you hadn't defended
yourself which is what the left has
excoriated you for
you'd be dead
you'd be dead
and that's not
that's not justice at all we're really
glad there are a lot of people just i
just want you know like for us we're
just really glad that you are not dead
and you're not
locked up
it really does like i've never had a
more vested interest i tell people i'm
not unbiased it was really
really i mean i've had conversations
with my wife about how heavy it was in
my heart i i know you don't celebrate
the loss of life but i celebrate that
you're still alive and you
you did what you had to do
so
sorry i know i didn't know when i get
all emotional call him a fat son of a
[ __ ] again let's do fine whatever you
want to whatever you want to get out of
this
has anyone told has anyone told you that
though does anyone have people to like i
know that you have a lot of people going
like hey we want you to appear on the
this show and
early on people are saying get him on
the show you know we reached out and we
never pushed it because we don't you
don't owe anyone
anything do you know that yeah
do you really know that mm-hmm okay
because robin williams is not your fault
scene it's hey hey kyle it's not your
fault it's not your fault um it's not
your fault boy it's not your fault no
you don't know anyone anything and it's
really easy to get sucked into this
industry by far
asking more of you because they admire
you just i hope you don't let that
happen well i think the best thing you
can do i mean it always sounds strange
but you know the best revenge is living
your best life and if you're going to
college and you want to do something and
spin this into the most positive thing
you can you can do something amazing
with your life
and i think it's good that you have the
opportunity to do that because there's
been so many people that have been in
your position that don't have that
option and there's been people you know
obviously falsely incarcerated white or
black anyway you know yeah and it just
comes down to the fact that
you yourself because you wore quick
enough
you know you get the second opera you
get the second chance i'm sure you look
at life and i shouldn't call it a second
chance that you did something wrong but
i just mean like you got through
something that most people i don't think
could handle and you should be proud of
yourself for that and and i just think
that it's good you go to school do what
you can
and you know just become a lawyer i'll
i'll have you as my first client dave
yeah zeal yeah well undoubtedly he will
need one i will expect to do it pro bono
my next dui i don't think you can get me
off yeah no those dilaudids don't come
cheap no i'm going at least 15 years do
you feel stronger from it i feel like
it's helped me grow as a person i've
learned so much especially from like
dave and lt they've taught me
they've taught me so much i'm the person
i am today because of them yeah
what was it like for you to see people
like uh i know you already had a message
for lebron james but people like batista
and these celebrities that's a good
message
uh yeah it was a good message i like the
message but uh
these other celebrities who even after
you were acquitted
continuing to i mean really commit libel
and slam batista said something
didn't he
he said something else i don't know what
batista did i know because i'm going to
say i i love wwe and i was a big batista
real man you love www like
my entire life like well i don't watch
it anymore well he said a lot of stupid
things so i could be mixing up stupid
celebrities saying stupid things i'm
pretty sure he did say something
more so about this is a state of affairs
in the united states and they turned it
all into a racial thing which is what's
so odd about this how do you think
i think i know the answer but i i want
to get your perspective how do you think
this was turned or why do you think this
was turned
completely falsely into a racial issue
well people just want to push their own
agenda on a case that has nothing to do
with race this is a case about
self-defense not politics not about race
not what you believe in it's about the
right to defend yourself but why do you
think they that it became that narrative
in the public eye they wanted to push
their own agenda and
they i think it was them trying to come
after the guns yeah
what is it
what does it do or how do you react when
people use the term vigilante
look i
didn't know what a vigilante was august
25th and
i wasn't a vigilante and i still don't
even know what a vigilante is i'm not a
vigilante it's a old guy with a mustache
who goes up with a sock with rolled up
quarters and hits guys in the subway
there's death dave yeah no he listen uh
that is the thing i've got some
questions yes i uh
yeah it's dave on a subway with a
blackjack hey you punk i go out as fat
man at night
well you roll i hesitate i hesitate to
stop crying and i usually just let it go
right yeah between cries he puts his
legs up like the blackhead and hook and
yells bangarang somebody's robbing a
7-eleven i'm like i'm just here for the
jerky that's exactly is it is it slushy
day yeah i thought they were free yeah
well they are sometimes uh one day a
year
one of my favorite days a year it really
is freezing and i realize i can afford i
can afford slurpees on any given really
the amount of time you spend in line to
save a dollar it's not worth it you
should just go every other day i'll tell
a story remember that later in life club
about free ice cream day at ben and
jerry's when i was on a date it did not
go well
uh are you dating oh no i am not dating
i am very single my dms are open oh jeez
look at that i was gonna say you did you
get fan mail from women you had to
yeah i got quite a few fan mail um what
was the weirdest one you got i had a mom
trying to
trying to set me up with her
um with her uh daughter
trying to say yeah their daughter yeah
was a daughter good looking i don't know
i didn't do it i didn't do a check or
anything why not what's wrong with you
ah what are you asexual it's okay
no but uh
hey man everybody's gay sometimes
only for you okay just tuesdays what's
today
uh
no you missed it by that much i know
but yeah but you had to get some weird
fan mail
i mean you had interesting but all the
support from the support mail from
everybody just met so much um who's the
most famous person that supported you
trump
uh
i think so i'm not sure did you get a
few though did you get like a few like
messages or letters from people that
were you don't have to say their names
or anything i think um i got a book from
an author um gary busey
uh no well he sends those to everyone
what which author yeah um i'm trying to
remember the name i have the book in my
bag in my uh
in my suitcase it's obviously not the
most famous if you have to get find the
name it's either it's either a token or
it's either a jk rowling or it's not a
star
it's the turner diaries
i don't know uh so probably trump
yeah yeah trump was probably the most
famous was it crazy meeting him yeah it
was very interesting uh we didn't he
just wanted to know about me and talk
about me we didn't talk about politics
or anything we just talked about who i
am as a person and
he
he asked questions and he talked with me
and my mom when you don't seem like a
political person
i don't know politics yeah i'll be
honest i'm not a i'm not a political
person but you watch this show every now
and then this is a this is more of like
a comedy show like you get to make fun
of dave yeah he gets it
yeah uh well thank you um was that the
first time that uh president trump had
was it the time that we saw when you and
mara go over how you reached out
personally before that uh
trump reached out and wanted to meet us
so
we met we i'm not going to turn down a
meeting with the former president so
and you wouldn't turn down a meeting
with the former vice president no i
wouldn't turn down a meeting with
president biden at all if he reached out
and i'd be
happy to tell my side of the story of
what happened anybody who wants to know
what happened well that would be an
important and interesting conversation i
mean until he nodded off 48 times and
[ __ ] his pants yes but i mean the
beginning of it would probably be really
good for the us like the first minute
and a half easy yeah and he came four
hours late yes because he had to load
him up like mr burns
putin was riding around with him on his
shoulders chicken fighting kamala and
willie brown
sorry this is this i'm sorry we do this
thing yeah we're still um we like to
have a laugh um a good laugh so you are
you're open to dating
i am i am very opening so maybe that's
what you want for christmas that's what
i want for christmas nice dame what are
you looking for in a woman uh
oh
yes
yes
tracks of land tracks of land yeah now
what are you looking for in a woman uh
you know some person that just wants to
like
uh date me for who i am um
and what i'm looking for in a woman is
i like i like a girl with a little bit
of butt okay yeah for sure some ways big
pets
big boobs big boobs dude you're you're a
guy let people get mad at that yeah i
love people every every guy in the world
is a hypocrite he cannot lie to a racial
issue no other brother can deny oh boy
i'll give you i got a question dig that
hole deeper there kyle i i was helping i
was doing two life crew
that's a good one i uh what was your
first meal outside of jail when you guys
eat something you wanted 50 chicken
nuggets did you really uh i ate about 38
of them so you so you so jail was a time
warp where you exited a nine-year-old
chicken nuggets what were fish sticks
not available
did you go get prime rib or something
yeah
donald's chicken nuggets with sweet and
sour sauce and dave came through and got
chicken nuggets and that's how i knew
this guy's good this guy this guy is a
guy
i turned out i was right he's been with
me ever since and fine meal he did miss
mcflurry but that's okay well dave you
know
if your machine is broken yeah i think
it's forgivable i don't know if you have
to call it okay yeah i wouldn't go that
far thank you so much for the chicken
nuggets dave i owe you one
how do you get 50 do they sell them in
50 yeah you just have to buy a bunch of
them well so you have to buy two 20s and
a 10. i think so yeah well good luck
getting that right in this pandemic
employee you could even yeah you mean by
320s really yeah well yeah but he
wouldn't let you buy anything did you
buy 60 and give dave 10. or did you buy
50 on the dot yes for one and you were
like nah
i was not sharing my chicken nuggets no
reason you didn't looks like you're
going back to jail i don't know why i
like to ask that but there's always got
to be something that makes you happy
instantly and i assume it was food right
food yes i love it explain dave i don't
know that's why i know that's why i
asked about the meal crying out loud
he's not the uh the other prosecutor who
looked like well marvel for crying out
loud he's saying i had a gut he didn't
say i was a yeah he didn't say that you
were a house yeah i didn't say
hey dave doesn't know i was gonna lose
both michael when he was there they had
the prosecutor's desk stapled
what was in his glass insulin yes
it was
could you see people take the stand when
he was like did you have to look around
him
uh it must have crossed your mind like
this this guy he's not gonna have the
energy to prosecute this long
yeah you gotta be thinking there might
be another lawyer
[Music]
sub n yeah yeah
like a hockey [ __ ]
um yeah you have the right to remain
silent
let's talk about that for a little bit
so what were you guys thoughts when um
bingo violated my fifth amendment right
i want to hear from you guys on this i
thought what a dick really i thought it
was incredible and so many people got
mad at the judge but i was very very
happy that he pointed out that you had
every right to do that and i think that
that made you look a lot classier just
the fact that you were doing that anyway
yeah i think you let the system work you
were trying to let your lawyers do their
job you weren't doing a bunch of
interviews you weren't doing any you
were just you were letting the system
work and the fact that he was trying to
demonize uh you for that i found to be
pathetic and i think it was so clear
that he was trying to score political
points when you when you took the stand
in other words you're waiting until you
can take the stand to say it accurately
and then he's saying yeah but before you
put what were you about to say uh so the
funny thing is um as soon as everybody
was in shock when i got called to the
sam i don't know what you guys were
thinking i was surprised i was gonna ask
you why you did that i wanted to tell my
story because i have nothing to hide
yeah because you know what it wasn't a
murder trial it was a self-defense trial
right and people don't say to stand in a
murder trial did your lawyers advise
against it at first no no i i told them
i want to take the stand and they agreed
with me um
and i was like i want to tell my story
but you were about to say something
about i was saying it was clear he was
trying to score political points talking
about you exercising your fifth when you
took the stand and you were about to say
something so the funny thing is right
before
everybody was in shock in the room and
they my lawyer was like we now call kyle
reading house to the stand and i'm like
let's do this game day and then we get
up there and the jury gets sent out and
then after that you see uh ada banger
just sprinting as fast as you can for
like the flash to get that giant notepad
he's been wanting to have yeah
yeah and then he had me on the stand for
several hours like i've never
yeah that was long i i was getting worn
out by the end i'm sure you guys were
that's a tactic they try and use and
just wear you down i mean fatigue makes
cowards of all men that's well that's
why any anytime you're being questioned
for anything it's just
see how long you can go until you change
your story and which shows when you
never did that you're telling the truth
and that's the thing like
he kept he kept asking me leading
questions and repeated he kept asking
different questions in different ways
and i'm like look
my story is the same like yeah i was
just getting irritated towards the end i
don't know if you could tell
i thought you were incredibly composed
honestly i thought if anything you were
you were getting a little uh uh more
mechanical just because i i i could see
that you sort of realized okay i see
what he's doing here he's reframing the
same question
is that how you felt you saw the
curveballs coming yeah i i noticed like
he was like asking me these questions in
different ways trying to get me to
answer differently and i was just like
no like yeah i was just i was frustrated
a lot because he asked about my call of
duty he asked about four doors more
[ __ ] um and then he asked about the
fire and every teenager it was a fire
yeah so i was just getting i was just
getting irritated like was it hot yes
no it was cold yeah yeah
would you say it was more of a red flame
like at the tip or the center of the
blue flame like a torchlight yeah you
know you know that's a good question the
fire um it was like
it was like over a car like orange color
um it had it was in inside the duramax
and like there was some smoke it was it
was going up um not to mention the
dumpster fire they tried to push
and then there was a dumpster fire
um
there there were some fires it was it
was it was a little bit brighter than
that orange towards the coals well
that's electric and we know that they
wouldn't have been able to afford that
uh so
my question is
no one
has been prosecuted as far as like
actually cage gross chris for aiming a
gun or in other words if you were
justified in self defense right people
who committed these
i mean they committed arson people who
committed serious you know um battery of
assault
nothing
the only person who
has been charged with this um which i
don't agree with which i don't agree
with the two people i agree with joshua
zaminski being charged i don't agree
with dominic being charged but those are
the only two what was dominic charged he
was charged with uh
providing a firearm to a minor which i'm
not gonna i don't want to jeopardize his
case so i don't want to talk about how
much of that did you um at that moment
though because uh you would ask a
question just even to go back to it did
you think there was a really good chance
there was going to be a mistrial i
thought that i thought that was only
outcome yeah it i did too for a little
bit and i was curious if that's what you
were feeling in the room did you like
the judge
yeah judge schroeder is a nice guy very
old school a very constitutional judge
yeah he was by the law and he's not a
judge you want to get sentenced by what
i hear from people but he is a judge you
want if you want a fair trial he's the
judge you want now you're born and
raised in wisconsin uh illinois
wisconsin yes wisconsin why don't you
sound
like schroeder why don't you sound like
talk talking like that
they got a little bit of that but they
don't have uh they don't have that one
you know no no um i don't have much of a
midwest accent do you find it funny when
you're listening to judges a little bit
no no no oh we found it hilarious but
we're all we're children
i did find this yeah it was hilarious
come on now
well i don't want to say giant but he's
a man baby
i'm sort of
he just came in
hot like he was like i'm just gonna go
all the way he knows i'm friendly yeah i
know um
did you when he was playing is it lee
greenwood who does the god bless the usa
song when you heard that
play his phone did you go
yes i didn't even realize it really no
god bless the usa how do you miss that i
don't know i i think i was just more
focused on like doodling on my notepad
the only thing more blatantly if it
started playing i'm too sexy for my
shirt and then you would have seen me
get i really wanted
i really wanted to do 20 different
sketches of what that phone was yeah it
could have rang off sexy for my clothes
too sexy for this gavel uh like oh my
gosh i can't believe that that was uh
you know my phone i thought it had it on
quiet oh dear don't get brazen with me
did you did you laugh at that oh uh i
don't know if you saw my face i was like
yeah i you you must have
my lip
my chest at the end of the trial were so
ripped up from how i had to bite my
cheeks and lips like the entire trial
because there was things that were just
happening i was just like so you were
able to find levity in moments
oh yeah you were able to go like okay if
i don't laugh i'll cry let me ask you
this before we go because we're going to
take questions on on mug club so i have
two final questions for you gage grow
skirts on the zoom call falling out of
his chair
all-time best part of the trial yeah was
it
bad
did you pee a little i i pissed myself
what's funny about nothing because he
was he was down for a while well because
he was probably high yeah i mean it was
like it was like a charlie chaplin
sketch it was hilarious tip over it was
like when marv and home alone is outside
the window slips on the ice he goes
straight down like how do you even do
that oh no it was like definitely like
uh
like so like a director yell to action
but you seem like you were laughing
before that on the zoom call oh i was
like i think it was laughing at
something mark was saying and then i saw
that and then i was really laughing were
you worried that if you laughed too much
would be used against you no no i just
um
there was a thing like i had to show
professionalism there yeah
i wouldn't say mission accomplished on
that one yeah so i i'd have to agree on
the best poker face well that you were
clearly tickled pink
yep yep everyone was laughing except
gage yeah well i don't even think he
knew where he was that's true
and finally you said he was looking
around on the ground for his arm yeah he
was looking to smoke some arm
stop dave
you can hold it in but i know
oh
he's been holding it in for so long we
don't want to happen he's going to get a
stress ulcer no kid it's me don't blame
him yeah blame him
yeah send me for the joke please i hope
i hope that i hope there is some kind of
restitution here as far as the the libel
and slander from the media you don't
have to talk about that no but you
deserve it you should never have to work
another day in your life
but work because you want to right now
we're focusing on linwood and john
pierce um
they're a bunch of liars i'm not going
to say much about them but well you just
did yeah they're just a bunch of liars
i'm not going to say much about that
piece of human [ __ ] uh
i'll bite my tongue um well it's proven
liars well he was almost on this show
and i said no i said uh i don't but
there's something smells fishy uh
lynnwood and so we've never had him on
the show you're gonna be accused of
being deep state now really yeah am i
yeah is that what linwood does yeah yeah
no okay
that's just that's when you start you
realize it's a grifter where if they
just accuse anyone who doesn't like them
of being deep state is he saying your
deep state apparently he's accusing me
of being handled which is just false i
make my own decisions yeah um but i'm
being by a bunch of people just not him
now being accused of being handled and
i'm not handled i make my own decisions
okay so you're focusing
what do you have to say to the people
though that said you went there because
of blm and it was racially motivated
this case has nothing to do with race
it's like
nothing absolutely
zero yeah it just doesn't make any sense
didn't enter your mind not at all and i
just would like to clear the air with
that because that was such the staple of
the media yeah
that it that i think it's just important
to just say that flat out that had
nothing to do with what that was about
um
mike you mentioned this before the show
and so uh i just wanted to bring it up
you said that you were just so grateful
for people who supported you from the
beginning 100
all the supporters it just means so much
and
the people in my circle i'll give a
quick long shout out i think that's the
camera you're talking to there yeah
sorry um i'll give a quick long shout
out to dave
um
dave lt
kenny tc john john's husband mark corey
natalie and just everybody who's helped
me through this without them
we wouldn't be here today and thank you
to all of you guys who've supported us
and donated africa freecalusa.org
it just means so much to us thank you
guys yeah i we have a lot of people to
love you we'll be getting a chat here on
mug club in a few minutes but uh
yeah we
we
mourned in a lot of ways with these
people we prayed for you we had team uh
you know kind of prayer groups about it
uh
it was something that weighed heavy on
hearts for a while and i told you you
saw he asked me where where we had the
streamers in confetti from when he was
not guilty yeah i said you should have
been you should have seen what we had
ready for uh if you lost oh yeah yeah
yeah what was gonna happen well you know
what we were right we were all ready to
go down to kenosha
uh
and not of course to actually
peacefully protest but mostly and very
effectively uh make our voices heard it
was one where gerald said it on the show
we said this is not something we're
gonna
sit by while a kid gets railroaded um we
were ready for it we were ready to leave
like the next day
so thank you guys for all the support
i've noticed i've been a big fan of mug
club for a while
that's actually you know what there's a
because the f was it the fbi or the the
police who went through your phone
because you gave it willingly yeah the
feds okay it was the feds so they would
have seen in your history some of our
shows
probably so we're not on a watch list
anyway there you go
i'll take the win where i can get it uh
watch what's that what's that sound just
a drone
yeah
uh uh yeah
just an r2d2 and a little plane
okay
everyone who's watching uh
thank you so much right now we're on
youtube uh we're gonna do some uh chat
take it from people on mug club uh
people have been supporters and kyle's
going to answer them directly you can
only answer what you want so you can say
pass it's not like jimmy fallon i'm not
going to break any eggs on your head or
anything like that really you didn't
bring the eggs out i didn't bring the
eggs out we were practicing before the
show yeah i know then we said we should
probably do comedy so so steven yeah did
this interview stress you i noticed you
got a little gray right here oh geez
well okay so dave's fat and um great
yeah it's called twins and uh titanium
rib cage but uh
you know it's nothing compared to your
stress you have no idea what you've just
done yeah you almost had to deal with
he's gonna go dye his hair now yes and
spend the rest it's nothing
percy not wetting the sponge what are
you gonna die a purple steven yeah i'm
gonna die purple get a nose ring yeah
and i will follow you everywhere you go
perfect say white supremacy can not win
and then i'll paint with my menstruation
and get a job at buzzfeed all right
people on youtube canvas smash the like
button
leave a comment below uh if you want
more ash wednesdays because every now
and then people say i don't like azure
wednesdays i like ash wednesdays and
leave your support for kyle because kyle
can go and check the comment section
usually i would say don't check the
comment section oh i do this will be a
good one oh god well you surely talk
about that with your shrink for crying
out loud don't do that geez
the prescriptions he's going to give you
and it's just like oh you you didn't
need wellbutrin you you just need to
stop reading the comment section
uh youtube
you're not gonna like this part piss off